[Music]
usually when i have a first-time
volunteer
come and be a part of a class their
faith says it all they're like oh my
gosh that was
the coolest thing i've ever been a part
of it's just a joyful
place
[Music]
my name is lauren beasley and i'm the
founder and executive director of move
inclusive dance
move inclusive dance is a dance studio
for everyone no matter their ability
level
i took my first dance class when i was
three years old from that point on it
was pretty much
my everything for me not only was it you
know
a fun activity but it was a place where
i could go and know that
it was safe for me to express my
emotions be myself
and it was just really a creative outlet
it was way more than just learning
steps not everyone loves to dance but a
lot of people do
it's the same for people with
disabilities right why wouldn't there be
a place
that they could go take a dance class
like i can they don't have that
opportunity
and because it was so transformative in
my life i felt like it was
my duty at that point to make it
possible
when we start the choreography what's
the very first thing
that we do in this combo yes emma show
them
we slide and we party
we slide and we party
when i'm driving to the studio i'm
probably planning
my classes for the day one of the things
that is different
um when you're teaching adaptive dance
you know you want to have
a good solid plan but you also have to
be prepared for
literally anything else to happen just
in case you know plan a doesn't really
go
as i thought and you know you just got
to be ready to
to move on your toes like that i oversee
all of the programming here at move
inclusive dance seeing if all the
students are getting their
needs met you have to get to know the
student
in order to understand exactly what they
need
and that's what inclusion is all about
it's a
dance class but it's adapting to whoever
is coming through the doors
we've tailored everything that we do
everything in the building every part of
our curriculum
to be adapted for people with special
needs
but at the same time people without
special needs are also welcome in the
classes
one too two one one and two from
here we do a little kick combination
with our feet
so if you're doing the feet it'll look
like this you go kick forward kick side
and then change it up again go forward
inside and then change it
up and if you're just doing the upper
body you're going to kind of just like
uh switch sides
switch sides building a better community
and a better place
is the ultimate goal no matter
where you come from what ability level
you have
you fit here we're going to make dance
work for you
when things shut down due to covid
we immediately had to pivot and so we
took things to a virtual setting
can someone tell me what improv dance is
raise your hand if you know
it it's way you just stand without any
instruction yes it's when you dance
without any instruction that's a really
good
description of it you know it's
definitely not the same as being in
person
but what i've found is that people
right now more than ever are craving
connection
our students that are doing the zoom
classes they love their weekly sessions
because they get to see their friends
we've had a handful of students that
have participated from out of state
because we're doing it online right so
you can really join from anywhere
and that's been a really really cool
thing to see
because it's you know just opened our
program up
it just requires a lot of energy from me
as the teacher
i am like worn out by the end of one of
our virtual classes
let's do this just follow me
[Music]
we use dance to get our message out
there but at the end of the day we just
want people
to be open to one another love one
another
and be positive
[Music]
you